yeah and my other thing too is I try not
to you know I try not to dive into like
the low-hanging fruit like beef [__]
like or like
you know I just some [__] I'm like I'd
rather I would just rather not
intentionally add to certain [__] now I
might end up adding to certain [__] but
it ain't you know some some of these
platforms and like I watch them you know
like I I got love for lad and all those
guys I watched that [__] all the time
but it's just like I don't know
for me it's like at the moment it's
working but you're right it's like the
guest based [__] is like at what a
certain point in time like
it's definitely gotta evolve into
something else and you guys have done
such a great job of
doing that because people are there for
you guys and if you guys haven't have a
guest
[__] sweet it's gonna be a great
interview because you guys do great
great conversations
um if you had Vlad on what would be the
first question you would ask them
uh
uh [__] man I don't know I've asked Vlad
to come on the podcast because he'll
text me sometimes or call me sometimes
and he said I didn't have enough viewers
for him
you said it wasn't popping so I'd like I
think I got the text in here but I mean
but I just I guess I don't know I mean
and I I respect hey hey also I wasn't I
didn't take that [__] personally I
wouldn't have taken that person I was
like hey bro I get it yeah all good like
hopefully one day you know
like he had hit me for a contact on
cannabis
oh you know what it was he called me
because he was like I didn't want to
send this over text he was like but you
know I'm looking at your numbers I'm
like you know and I'm like dude you're
[__] Rich yeah so for you to like
take time away from your family take
time away from your business I get it
bro all good I didn't take anything flat
is Rich he's never told us that he tells
us that a lot I had no idea I mean have
you seen the way he dresses no he's not
on camera well no sometimes when he is
it's like [__] Louis every you know
how they say you can either wear the
designer or let the designer wear you I
would say the designers wearing Vlad he
walks into sacks and just give me the
mannequin yeah give me the whole [__]
give me the glasses give me the [__]
shorts give me the shoes give me the
socks yes you know it's uh shots of Life
by the way rap phenomenon was it the
first one it was a rap phenomenon too
that he was the the Tupac one Tupac one
Tupac one was great was that the one
Green Lantern I believe so yeah him and
him and Green Lantern Green Lantern's a
goat huh absolutely yeah as green should
do more podcasting I feel like me and
him were just together in Vegas and uh
he has a lot of stories he probably just
can't tell that's that's what it is
because green green lab had great
conversations where I'm like this would
be the greatest he's got tons of those
and
I just man
I just want to know like you know the
Eminem [__] what happened with this I
mean we know what happened with the
shady [__] with like the Jadakiss G Unit
[__] or whatever yeah but
this guy was Jay-Z's DJ Eminem's DJ and
he's Nas's DJs no way it's a goat he
doesn't have some wild but but if you
know Green which you know him there
there's just I don't think there's a
chance in hell he'll ever like really
dive into a lot of that [__] he told me
though a couple weeks ago on 420 because
we were doing Jardine in Vegas together
and he was like
I'm gonna do your podcast when I have
something to promote
I did say that similar yes yeah you told
me the same thing he has nothing to
promote you know he put out that Big Pun
Jada song which but green is kind of
like uh speaking of Vlad I've seen
vlad's like moved into the mafia part of
YouTube which I I get I respect it you
have to grow the page but you know
picking the people that already have
huge numbers in the mafia space and
telling the same stories that were out
already but I get it Vlad is a different
audience green is like that but music
industry-wise when I look at the mob
[__] I'm like if this guy's telling the
story
obviously either ratted or he's lying
because he wouldn't be able to sell this
he wouldn't be Irene is like that for me
with hip-hop he can't get on a mic and
talk about it he wouldn't be someone you
could interview because you even see
people in hip-hop that go on these like
the behind the scenes guys that tell
these crazy stories I'm like
I could be lying because
the people that tell this story aren't
going to tell it I feel like Vlad has
one of those guys on the show every two
weeks oh it's entertaining we are like
yo there's just this random like
bodyguard
and he's just saying like I know who
killed Tupac I mean I was under the
[__] I was under the Mercedes I had a
GoPro at the time before they came out
and then vlado like he interviewed he
interviewed someone that pulled up on a
bicycle to the Tupac scene I was like
are you kidding I believe it was the
first responder he just happened to be
on a Schwinn are you are you serious I
swear to God
listen I have a lot I have a lot of
disagreements with Vlad uh that's great
though him and I I guess don't get along
I don't know I have a lot of issues with
people I've never met or spoken to right
um
but uh yeah when there's positive things
to watch Vlad related I watch yeah I
just watched uh him and Charlemagne and
I watched uh him in uh who was he look
at the growth of Charlemagne I watched a
few of those clips too yeah
Charlemagne's a grown ass man now I love
it it's great oh it's like finding out
Santa isn't real [__] hey I've never
even mature